he's a liar he's mentally incompetent
you guys know if you're if you're losing
it if people are not believing that he's
capable and everything else what do you
have to do you have to scare the hell
out of everybody what do you think when
you hear Trump Republicans calling you
the Biden crime family
or I have one congresswoman the Biden
crime family sold out America Marjorie
tiller green he's a liar he's mentally
incompetent um and let's not even talk
about what let's go Brandon means but
you have US senators holding signs that
say that it's hard to realize our
country isn't it I mean to look at it
what we used to have and um what the
other side the extremists have turned
this country into I mean we would never
see things like that say 10 years
ago no no uh we would never see people
calling the president Hitler all the
time and all of his supporters white
supremacist we'd never see that would we
Emily absolutely not I mean first of all
the best part about America is the free
speech and for them to say oh we would
never see that 10 years ago maybe
because 10 years ago our country wasn't
in a place that's as bad as it is today
and secondly she said let's not even go
into let's go Brandon what that means no
go into it tell what it me you Joe Biden
said it himself this Joe Biden has said
it it's so funny to me I mean I can't
even take an interview like this
seriously I'm I'm being serious right
now because I know every single thing
was verified 300 times every question
was pre-approved 700 times and it's so
phony and fake I don't even want to hear
it and it means nothing to
me yeah Ari that's the other part of all
of this right as a new media guy like
just watching these things watching
these debates now watching these Town
Halls watching these interviews it's
just it feels like we're just at the end
of what old media was it was good at
some time it was necessary it was just
growing as our technology grew but
something ain't working
anymore yeah I look at the corporate
media now the same way I do as the
Italian mob back in the day they're just
able to get away with murder constantly
uh and uh right now at least the mafia
was cool and they ate good
food right and if we're even looking at
like all of the evidence that we have
now on uh Biden the corruption in the
family within Hunter Biden Joe Biden the
brothers really there's just so much
evidence that we've had uh that paints a
very clear picture of what is happening
and that there really was serious
corruption going on and the fact that
the media has been able to really make
it so that half of the country still
after multiple years doesn't believe
that any of that stuff is uh true well
it's really impressive and it's also
really scary did this anchor bring up
the fact that Biden son is doing cocaine
and they found cocaine in the white
house or
no um I didn't see the full interview
but I'm guessing it was not mentioned
the cocaine in the white house with the
cocaine
son yeah so if we're not going to
address like current events surrounding
um the president's son doing dealings
with Russia and doing literal drugs in
the white house it might not be the most
honest
interview